depuis l'aube des temps il y a eu des
vampires
et puis il y a moi prêt à débuter
salut les gars stream team le 29 avril
Stream TV likez
j'ai reçu un appel des personnels de
Steven rector lui et sa femme
personnellement demandé à l'équipe de
strip-tease devenir à son manoir au
Nouveau-Mexique pour discuter à propos
de son contrat d'ambassadeur massif
c'est qui cette idiot
vous avez aucune idée à quel point vous
êtes dans la merde je serai prévenu et
si ces gens-là ne sont pas seulement
cupides mais diaboliques
tout va bien se passer OK
bienvenue à tous la reine du shopping en
ligne le roi de YouTube la déesse des
réseaux sociaux je dirais pas déesse
pourquoi les gens disent ça tout le
temps
je viens de recevoir un message d'en bas
ils sont prêts pour recevoir David c'est
là où je voulais
où est David
[Musique]
bienvenue dans le reste de ta vie
tu es prête on verra à quelle heure
on a pas signé pour ça c'est ça la
vérité ma grande
allez on y va
c'est l'heure
[Musique]
des vents ça c'est cool